こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
あの　ぼく！
♪〜
あんまり自分の弱いとこ
見せたくないんですけど。
オセロめちゃくちゃ弱いんですけども→
こんなアプリがあるらしいです！
[拍手]
おお。
たしかに将棋とかオセロとか
めちゃくちゃ強いコンピューター→
とかAIとかが出るって話は
よく聞くんですけども↗︎
↘︎が出たっていう…
聞いたことがなくて。
色々ちょっと見てみたんですけども
あの…
負けられないらしんですよ
どうしても！　ぼくも弱いんですけど
どうしても勝っちゃう。
↘︎思ったので　今回　私
そんな最弱オセロAIに→
負けてみようと思います
はい　というわけでこちらですね
フッｗ
あ　すげぇ。
それでも1717人
勝ってる人がいますね
それでも33万2100敗ってもう…
ほぼほぼの確率で負けちゃう
レベルっスね
これ　逆に負けてみたいところ
ではありますね
では私から行かせていただきます
あ　ぼく　黒…っぽいっスね
ま…負ければいいんでしょ
ちょっと　悪い手を打って…
♪〜
<この時 はじめは思った>
<「このAI ガチで弱い！」>
結局　オセロって1番外の囲いを
取っちゃうと有利になっちゃうんで…
あ　上手いな
負ける方法を
ちゃんと知ってるぞ　この人 (？)
これでどうだ
なんとしても1番外の…
囲い…　あ　OK OK
今のでいいです
1番外の取らせれば
負け…れる気がする
♪〜
やっぱ　オセロめっちゃ
弱いんですよね　ほんとに。
なんかオセロとか将棋系とか
マジで驚くほど弱くて→
びっくりしてるんですけど
あー…オレこれ取っ…ちゃうか。
いやまだ粘るぞ
♪〜
おぉ悩んでる悩んでる！
おし！　いいぞいいぞ！
負けれるぞ　これ！
いや上手いこと立ち回ってる気がするぞ
この角だけは
取っちゃいけない気がする…
はい！　どうだ
♪〜
なんとかして負けたい
置い…置くしかないな
置いちゃいますね1回
ヤバイヤバイ絶対ここ取るしかない…
これ1回とらっ…取っちゃいます
角。
♪〜
ヤバイ！
角置くしかない！
♪〜
こっから相手の猛反撃が
来るはずなんで…
♪〜
ヤバイ…
ここ置くことによって…
♪〜
あぁ角じゃぁん！もぉ〜〜
上手ァ！
ヤバ…
え…
くっそ…
くそぉッッッ
このAI…
すごい！ほんとになんか
負けようと思って戦ってるんですけど→
あまりに弱すぎて
勝っちゃいますねこれは。
や　すごいぞこれ
もう1回やってみます
よーし頑張って負けるぞー
でもなぁ…わかんない…
負けようと思ったことないからね
戦略がわかんないんだよなぁ
ぜ　絶…対　間違いなく
角は取…っちゃあダメですね
角取っちゃうと勝…つんで
くっっっそ…
ヤバイ　マジで角取るしかないな
フッｗ
負け…じゃない　勝ちましたー！
くそ…いや嬉しくねぇー！
え？これほんとすげーなぁ
え　ヤバイよ。ほんとに。
外(そと)以外を固める作戦が
1番いい気がするんだよなぁ
ぁ…やべ　ダメだ
普通に勝っちゃった…
なんならパーフェクトバトルだったわ
待って待ってヤバイ！
え…　えぇ　すごいよ
え　これ　1717人…の…
勝った人達マジですごい…
あ　違うわ
1717人の負けた人達マジですごいよ
このAIマジで弱いぞ
ヤバイ！ヤバイ！ヤバイ！
マジでヤバイ！
自分が強いって錯覚しちゃう　これ
ハァッ
負けん！
ハハ負けん…ｗ
いやこれすごいっスよ…
ぼくオセロほんと苦手なんで
弱いんですけど
弱いからこそ多分…
負け方もわからないんでしょうねぇ
ちょっと　もうちょい頑張ってみるわ
♪〜
フッ…
ｗｗｗ
あぁ…いやマジほんと笑っちゃうぐらい
弱いんだけど。
無理だァーーー！！！！
なんて言えばいいんだろう。
やー逆に気持ちいいのかとか
よくわかんないんですけど→
逆の発想ですね。
最弱のオセロのAI
本当に弱いです
ぜひ挑戦してみてください
じゃあな！
痛っ
[通常ED]